what's going on guys so I'm feeling a
little bit down I've been getting a lot
of requests for months to review more
video games the last game I reviewed was
Majora's Mask for 3d s it's been some
months and I feel bad that I haven't
done as many game reviews as of late so
I've decided to make it up to you this
game splatoon had a very interesting
impact on me
I discovered it in a very strange way so
to make it up to you guys my wife and I
have been working on a short documenting
my odd encounter with discovering the
game splatoon enjoy
hey hun I rented this game at family
video I like the colors I'd like to
watch love Sam stupid get it over with
yes hi you wouldn't happen to have the
splatoon amiibos would you I'm looking
for the boy the girl and possibly the
squid or if you had the 3-pack that
includes all of them that would be
wonderful
hi yes I'm looking for the splatoon
amiibos would you happen to have those
yes I'm a full-grown man yes I'm looking
for the splatoon amiibos there's a boy
or girl and a squid you have them
splatoon that's right I went out and
bought this thing even though I still
have an extra day left on my rental I
still wanted to buy it and I'm still not
done playing this game because it's the
type of game that is not going to end
any time soon especially in my brain
because I'm waking up and I keep
thinking paint things now splatoon
do it basically what splatoon is is you
have various paint weaponry you have a
paint roller you have various paint guns
you have special items paint bombs all
types of things
imagine a paintball game except the
object is to cover your territory or
turf and as much paint as possible
there's two teams four players on each
team and when the timer is up whoever
covered their turf in their paint the
most wins that's just the online
battling part there's also a
single-player campaign as well it's a
little short it's a bit brief but it
actually is challenging and I enjoy the
single-player campaign I wasn't
expecting a 20-hour splatoon
single-player campaign I had a great
time with it but really where this game
shines is it's addictive gameplay and
the fact that you can continuously level
up your character as well as get new
abilities with your weapons and your
clothes that you put on these things all
aid in battle and even though you can't
really work out team strategies because
there isn't voice chat I actually like
that I don't like random kids just
yelling in my ear it's kind of horrible
I've never liked voice chat so I like
the idea that you really have to teach
yourself how to be good at this game and
you have to learn how to make your team
better like you can't just like hey go
over here and I'm going to go over there
you have to actually make strategies in
your head based all the things you're
seeing and I think that's actually a
plus I've always been a big Nintendo fan
my entire life and I've always tried to
support Nintendo when it came to this
game though I had no interest in playing
it the only reason I even thought of it
was because my buddy Andre from black
nerd comedy on YouTube took part in this
big splatoon mess fest he was like hey
that was pretty fun and I was like okay
what's this all about and then my wife
rented it for me and I love this game it
was a ton of fun one of the things this
game really reminded me of was the Tony
Hawk pro skater mode in which you skated
along your skatepark and whatever you
skated on became your color and then you
owned that area because there are
legitimate skatepark level
in this game as well with half pipes and
everything the single-player mode is
definitely very inspired by Super Mario
Galaxy with launch pads that launch you
all around and for me when I was
spraying my paint around it reminded me
of spraying floods water tank and Super
Mario Sunshine so basically it's like
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater graffiti mode
combined with Super Mario Sunshine in
Super Mario Galaxy and if you liked all
those games you're probably going to
have a good time with this one in
regards to flaws it does feel a little
bare-bones there needs to be more DLC
Nintendo has promised they're going to
be releasing more levels and more things
you can do because right now it doesn't
really justify the $59.99 price I would
say if this game was $49.99 that'd be
perfect so maybe if you can find it used
or wait until they price drop because 60
seems a little much for the fact that
there isn't quite as many things as I
would like there to be and there were
like two occasions of lag that's it the
rest of the time was perfect I was very
impressed actually simple fact of the
matter is I play games to have fun I do
enjoy shooters I enjoyed The Witcher 3
you know there are games like that that
are fun for what they are but in the
long run I really love these types of
addictive games that are just freaking
fun like that's why we play games I mean
it's cool to play a game like Metal Gear
Solid which oh my gosh I can't wait for
phantom pain and I wish silent Hills was
happening that was one of the biggest
disappointments ever but there is a
special place in my heart for just
addictive fast paced gameplay like
splatoon offers and I had a blast with
this game I'm going to give splatoon an
8.5 out of 10 in all honesty this game
really isn't that childish there's a
great third person shooter lurking in
the middle of this game and if you can
discover that aspect of it I think
you'll actually be pretty impressed guys
thank you so much as always for watching
I'll try to do more game reviews from
time to time I know the primary audience
on my channel is definitely movie
reviews and I'm the same way
games are kind of secondary but when I
find a game that is this surprising and
this addictive I feel like I want to
share it with you guys
speaking of requests I have gotten so
many to finally review attack on Titan
and I'm gonna do that for you guys this
month now I'm still doing my promotion
for crunchyroll.com you may have seen me
wearing that hoodie in the beginning
they actually sent that to me for free
that was really awesome
them thank you if you guys would like to
watch attack on Titan for free before I
do my review I can give you 30 days of
crunchyroll for free if you go to
crunchyroll.com slash kris stuckman you
can get 30 days of crunchyroll for free
these guys are anime fans like myself
and they want to make it easily
accessible in a legal way for us in
America that's so awesome
so if you go to crunchyroll.com slash
chris tucker and you can get 30 days for
free my gift to you guys for being
awesome and look forward to my attack on
titan review i thought it'd be cool if
you guys could actually watch it before
I review it give you some preparation
for the show guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you did like
this you can click right here and get
stuck menage